here from uh uh nfl network mike
compadre
who's uh whose show good morning
football had a huge milestone this week
not just
back in studio together but uh had its
1000th show which is pretty cool
uh the ten questions with kyle brandt
podcast is on a post-election week
mandated bye week
oh so um we're we're
we've got everything in the nfl and
anything that we want to talk about with
kyle brandt as always back here in the
rich housing show how are you brother
well i thought it was just wine that i
needed rich to this morning
and last night and then i i i'm running
to see the picture of ryan fitzpatrick
that you're talking that you're talking
about
and it hit the spot yeah i feel so much
better those those shorts are high
they're hot yes they're real and they're
spectacular yes i did
uh it's it makes me think um uh
last night wasn't the only polling error
in miami
yes let's hope now i just said those
words here on peacock
sometimes the filter doesn't catch
everything you know
uh yeah man at least though
you know i'll take that as a positive
sign that
that despite the gut punch that he
received um and was so
uh honest and truthful about that he is
uh providing the levity uh that he
always has
and uh and you need that as a football
team to get through
a season that appears to be uh going up
for miami when you agree it's going way
up i i i it was it
wasn't it rich catherine was it
catherine bach who who played
uh daisy duke yes sir and that that's
who it was i think
i guess that was her name yes um it's
it's it's a hell of a look
and a hell of a look for the for the
dolphins coming off a win now
and 1-0 in the post fitch fits magic era
in
in a game in which you know we do these
things and we look at tua and we're like
well how do you grade two uh do you give
it an a a b
it's that old i gave him an eye for
incomplete i used to get that in biology
i don't i can't even give him a grade
and i they gave out eyes at princeton
uh yeah i i think you could choose there
was like this option where like
two times in your four years there you
could get some sort of
non-grade and i cashed them in both
first semester freshman year it was some
sort of flip in the cracks i found
so you didn't princeton had an eye in it
and uh you were the one who provided it
uh but you know look i'll tell you what
i i i pointed out yesterday i can't wait
for this coming
uh week miami versus arizona not just to
see
obviously tua and his first career road
start and and
nowhere to go but up in terms of
efficiency and uh
production but this is going to be the
first game that kyla murray plays in the
nfl
and he'll have many more to come but
this is the first one where he's the og
where he's the one who's got more
experience he's the one who's been there
done that he's the one already with the
offensive rookie of the year award
not trying to uh take on uh a veteran
quarterback or someone more veteran than
him with a plucky team like this is the
team that's five and two
and he's the guy who's the og
quarterback that tua would love to
have uh a season like he had last year
and i'm wondering how that might
actually
suit him i think he's gonna enjoy that
yeah the older statesman
kyler murray we um it's gonna be a fun
show too we talked we talked about this
this morning
and we were just all these great young
quarterbacks and we've done so much joe
burrow hype and uh we
were asking you know there's a bunch of
them now who are 24 and under
and it's speaking of an elder statesman
lamar jackson i think is 24
right now and then there's all these
herberts and burrows and this great crew
of quarterbacks and we said
you got to pick one right now who you
going with start your franchise next 10
years this is your guy
and burleson next to me virtually said
i'm going to go with lamar i'm going to
stick with lamar and i said all right
what if you made lamar
uh harder to hit you strapped the bigger
arm on him
and made him just as fast as he is now i
think he'd have kyla murray
and that's that's the biggest compliment
i can give kyle murray is that
he looks like a more talented lamar
jackson at this point
it's wild and i know lamar's had a rough
week rich and
lamar is is getting dragged as the kids
say
but i look at it more as a tool for with
which to prop up kyla murray because
he's the guy for the next 10 years i
would take over any of them yeah what do
you make of
um the the ravens performance against
the steelers four
lamar turnovers my my initial first
blush and i'll give you the floor
to either agree disagree build off
whatever you wish
is that it's it's becoming time for
lamar to win one of these games
uh because january has not gone his way
and i know
that one of these games could also
include that
you know boat racing of new england on
sunday night football last year that i
slept through because i was in
london at the time about 19 hours behind
but um
you could count that up as one but he
needs he needs to
take one of these games and not try and
pick up a first down with his legs but
actually
throw one in the end zone like he was
attempting dude to win it with
mere seconds to go he's got to connect
they've got to come up with one of them
kyle yeah and this this is the time
let's set the stage here let's set the
stage for lamar jackson the reigning nfl
mvp
all right he currently is the 19th 19th
rated passer in the nfl okay
his best lineman is gone for the year
his best corner is out with covin
the energizer of the offense the the
mouthpiece of the offense mark ingram
also hurt and his alleged
number one wide receiver is tweeting and
erasing things about i gotta get the
ball
okay that's now that's not cataclysmic
that's not defcon one but that's not
pretty either
this is the game in which lamar jackson
has to be like
i'm taking over this is the call at the
jordan golf the kobe said give me the
ball i'm getting
40. get out of my way i don't need him
to put up monstrous stats every single
year
the season after mahomes threw 50
touchdowns his stats were very modest
but he went won the super bowl and he
beat lamar and he won the big games
i don't need lamar to set the world on
every fl and fire every week to be
considered a superstar but at some point
you have to say damn it we're winning
this game
all the chips are down everything's
against us people are saying i don't
have one in me
we gotta go on a run now if you're the
mvp this is the time to go let it rip
yeah i guess the high water mark would
be that win over new england last year
when new england was undefeated and
the ravens put it on him um and
we haven't really seen anything
significant
like that i mean kansas city's gotten
them and now
you're right on it we we um i would i
would pose this to you
we this came up this morning too
hypothetical the classic quarterback
hypothetical
uh you are down five you're on your own
25 yard line minute 40 and one time out
left
if you were to start making a list of
the quarterbacks you want in that
situation
any pick any quarterback you want and
you started saying all right give me
russ give me my homes give me rogers
give me brady
at what point in that list do you say
lamar jackson's name
i don't know if it's in the top 10 i
don't know if it's in the top 12.
great player great stats great
highlights great everything
but in that situation the go 8 goes 75
yards and win the game of the game
winning touchdown pass
are we in the 15s because i want matt
stafford before him
i want a healthy dak prescott before him
and i don't want to
roll mar through the mud he's great and
he's very young
but at some point you got to creep up
that list because that's the more
important list than any number or any
stat you could put up the guys i want at
the end of the game
kyle brandt here co-host good morning
football 10 questions with kyle brandt
podcast that's on its bye week this week
um right here on the rich eisen show
did i uh you you obviously talked about
the bears on the show this week correct
i i'm actually i we didn't i just
mumbled about it i can't really make the
words about the bears anymore rich i
i've
i've gotten to a point of paralysis and
i'm in a dark place
a glass case of emotion hand up i'm just
going to put the hand up right now
i panicked so in the worst kind of panic
i twitter panicked and around the end of
the third quarter of that bear saints
game
and i just came i blurted out put your
biscuit in i can't take it anymore put
him in i think you got to put him in and
deal with it afterwards i
folded i i broke and then sure enough
nick foles started getting hot
so i'm in a bad bad place can you can
you provide any guidance or
any hope one might for you as a jet fan
can you do that for me as it bears
enthusiasm are you asking me to be you
is that what you're asking me to be um
because that's kind of
that's the that's the map that's the
matt neggie phrase um
so yeah um geez
i i i don't know man because it it's
pulling teeth
it's pulling teeth playing offense and
it does seem to miss
that guy who's like screw it nothing's
happening in front of me
i'm gonna take off and pick up a first
down with my legs the rpos that are
being run
can actually make somebody hesitate
um you know because i could actually
have the ball and run with it the
problem is is that sin
if he gets so in love with it he's not
looking down the field and either way
allen robinson is pissed at the world
so i i don't know what the answer is
right now and if you go to trubisky how
do you look
the rest of the locker room in the face
when
these guys have been told over the last
month this is the guy and foles has
rightly
taken the reigns as if he is the leader
of the team
uh do you just cut him off at the knees
right in the middle of the game against
the saints
and and you sit saint nick down the king
of the comebacks down to see what
trubisky has and then
what happens next i i i just think you
cannot go back to mitch un
unless nick gets hurt that's it i think
that's about it
and i i rich i'm with you and this is a
spoiler alert listen
i i know matt and aggie a little bit i
like to think i have a good sense of how
he thinks i very uh invested in chicago
media the beat writers the guys who were
there every single day
i i they're not putting travisky back in
it's not happening
and i don't care if they come out this
game against tennessee and
nick foles has thrown two interceptions
and they're down 12. they're not doing
it
like he has seen everything he wants to
see for mitch trubisky a guy who was
never his quarterback he gave
it a couple years to try to make it work
and then a couple weeks this week and
he's out he i don't think he's mentioned
nick foles
and the only way trubisky gets in is the
folks gets hurt so all these people
saying put mitch in myself included
it ain't happening that ain't gonna be
the savior they're going to go down
or go up with nick falls we've reached
the uh ask kyle brent some poll question
uh questions of our of our of our
program
see we we have production value for you
kyle we don't just call you up and just
throw words around you know we actually
have production value
um so all right give it to me let me
john king this thing at the big screen
go to the beginning well i'm i'm i'm a
kornacki guy because he reminds me of
scott hanson
oh well then then i'm counting me in
there too i love scott hanson
who's into it is into into it like it's
the greatest thing ever
like uh like you know scott hanson and
his quad box need a room
um and and kornacki and his big board
they kind of need a room together
um they have mackie bragged every five
seconds that he hasn't used the restroom
yet that's about i have not heard that
i have not heard that but i i'm assuming
he has not peed in
uh since you know florida started
returning
um results so ask the poll question of
uh kyle brandt he's got you got two
right you got a football and a pumpkin
yeah i haven't thought of the pop
culture one yet but we'll get to that
after the
football kyle as you probably know today
is the 38th birthday of
devin hester who is
most deserving of hall of fame
enshrinement
of these four devin hester julian
edelman
philip rivers marshawn lynch
i love the question uh this is this is
wheelhouse as they say this is a
beltai fastball for so we say frank
thomas or mark grace for me
okay uh devin hester is my favorite
all-time chicago bear
wow uh with respect to sweetness i was
too little too young to really get the
sweetness factor but i love devin hester
and i've been on record of this i think
that devin hester should be in the hall
of fame uh with respect to those other
guys
for the simple reason of i understand
the argument against it you know you
only have so many plays on the field and
there's guys who've done this and done
that
i think every argument is trumped when
if you are
definitely and far away the best player
ever at your position by far there's no
comparison
you're in now that goes for ray guy
i believe that goes for adam vinatieri
and it damn well better go for devin
hester
love marshawn phil all those guys devin
hester might be which i know is is a
polarizing one
is a hall of famer because no one to
ever return kicks and punts is even
close to him i think he should be in ken
yeah i said before that uh twice i went
to a game and watched
um the rare feat of somebody pulling off
what we were expecting of him in
spectacular fashion and it was kevin
hester
twice i saw him at the super bowl where
i couldn't believe the colts actually
kicked him the ball
and then he actually did what what he
was doing all year long
um and then uh and then the other time
was when he broke dion's record
uh in the georgia dome on thursday night
football with dion in the building
um when we were all like can he really
do it tonight like with dion here and
all of us here in a nationally
television audience and he did it
i mean that was special special i i got
to be a couple times too rich
it was unlike anything in that era that
you just couldn't even kick it anywhere
near him it would return it
i'm sure you i'm sure you're aware of
the story with the bears and the colts
in the super bowl is that for an entire
two week ramp up
tony dungy was on record with the with
the media and his players saying we are
not kicking it to hester
we're crazy we're nowhere we're kicking
devin hester and the night before the
game he's
his pride got to hold him and said no
we're kicking it to hester we're not
afraid of any man they kicked it the
hess of the rest is history
so um you know chris have we received
what i'm
expecting uh which is the trolling tweet
what about steve tasker from a bills fan
several several taskers is it because i
said
that tasker should be in two best
special team player of all time
you know like if devin hester is being
talked about what about steve tasker i
mean that's coming
it's already arrived has it oh yeah
several times but does tasker go in with
his uh
extra big helmet hmm was it him that
wore the
casket didn't have the helmet that was
kelsey there was a different guy in the
bills
i don't think tasker had the extra
helmet but i i do wonder
if i if did i open the pandora's box
here the greatest long snapper
of all time did they go in i got i wish
i could remember the guy's name but the
long snapper for the lions right now
it's been there about 20 years and he's
a legend amongst the lions i feel like
if if we're going to say every position
the best has to go in he has to go in
two doesn't every nfl season have to
have a long snapper who retires after 20
years of long snapping i don't it just
seems to me that every team
usually has one of those guys you know
it seems like
how about hacker man that guy is a
freaking oh man
i know oh you had a poll question okay
now we got a pop culture one
uh kyle it's ralph macchio's birthday
today
as i'm sure you're aware uh what's the
best movie where the villain gets served
karate kid back to the future a
christmas story or friday
oh man those are great choices um
man a biff cannon obviously a legend um
we've talked a bunch about karate kid
because i know rich you introduced it to
your kids
i did and that movie it can be flipped
on its head very easily where johnny
lawrence is actually kind of an innocent
bystander who gets beat up by mr miyagi
so for that reason
it's it's the it's that cackling laugh
of skutt farkas
in in the alley and ralphie uh
scott farkas was some sort of and that's
got scott farkas yeah some sort of
sociopath in a [ __ ] skin cap with braces
who was just all he wanted to do was
hurt children and there's one day when
uh ralphie couldn't take it anymore he
went absolutely ballistic on them
and the funniest part is when he's he's
beating up scott farkas he's just
wailing away on him with hammer fists as
they would say in mma ralph is supposed
to be swearing
you know because again his mom catches
him swearing but he can't swear because
it's still sort of a family
movie so he just does what joe pesci
does and home alone he says what you'll
do
and he doesn't swear at all but he's
just working scott farkas and it's
unbelievably satisfying to watch so
i'm gonna go with a christmas story even
here in november ladies and gentlemen
kyle brandon is always a comprehensive
well-thought-out well-reasoned
answer i i you know i i always
appreciate your responses on this so
we'll post that too and see if people
agree with him how does that sound
it's rock and roll i'll do that i don't
know if you um uh
how old are your kids again kyle i have
six and four
six and four okay uh boy boys girls what
do you have
six-year-old boy and a four-year-old
daughter i got one of each okay i told
this story the other day
uh that my my daughter's seven-year-old
daughter when we were watching the
witches
um on saturday night and she got a uh
every time that she got scared
of what was on the screen she put her
fingers in her ears and calmed herself
down by singing the folgers jingle
she actually did that the folgers jingle
by uh that's part of waking up it's
folgers in your cup
yes wow that's what she thinks
that's what i i wasn't expecting it it
brought her to her safe place
um it really i she did it about three
four times before i realized what the
hell she was doing
so you're telling me rich that uh i
think angelica houston is ripping her
face off and revealing herself
as a witch right and uh your daughter
who whose name i i remember is
millionaires
yes her middle name is mattingly her
first name is taylor this was the new
version so it's anne hathaway not
angelica houston but okay yes but you're
you're you're spot on here that actually
happened
in my house are you a folger's household
we are not
we are not a folger's household by the
by the way an excellent way to phrase it
too um
because when you're talking about what
type of coffee do you drink
in the morning it's it is a perfectly
are you a household of a certain type of
coffee
we are not a folgers household but i
guess they see the commercial and have
picked up the jingle and i had no idea
why she would connect it to having a
nice safe moment
so you know that's a great endorsement
please the folgers people reach out to
taylor that's right exactly
uh thanks for the call kyle uh congrats
by the way on the uh the
the thousandth show that's probably
pretty cool man
it's unbelievably cool we had great
little messages sent from coaches and
players all over the league from george
kittle to frank reich
it was unbelievably good and uh out of
the way you know rich that you know
about tv the way this show was thrown
together at the last second with no
auditions or anything we were lucky to
make it to ten episodes so ten
uh a thousand is is is asinine but it's
incredible it's really fun and your pod
that's available on the ringer in
spotify do you have a guest for next
week teed up that you want to promote or
what do you got for me yeah all right
i'll i'll do this
and i'll i'll bid you would do i have
two in the two in the tank
two in the not in the tank and the can i
should say i was in the tank in the can
uh the first one as i know a friend of
yours is was the great joel mchale
uh yeah it's fantastic and talked at
length about giving the
white house correspondent dinner address
and doing 20 minutes of material
uh everyone from obama to chris christie
and uh
had great great political takes and then
the last one i will leave
as a blind item as i once did with tim
robbins when i said it's the
the movie star of the one of the
greatest movies ever made the next one
which will be out in two weeks is
the lead singer of a
multi-multi-multi-platinum rock band
that is toured all over the world and we
all know their songs it is the lead
singer of that band
wow i mean i don't even there's a lot of
breadcrumbs there
there's a lot there's a lot i mean he's
american okay he's american american
gentleman
is it dave grohl it might be dave grohl
uh it might we'll know in two weeks time
but i know my last breadcrumb is this
gentleman has a
a distinct and direct tie to both the
nfl
and major league baseball it's going to
bring the house down i i wish it was two
weeks from now because
we could talk about it because there's
so many funny cool things well the neat
thing is you're on every wednesday
because you're cool enough to do it and
we love it so
thanks for the call kyle we'll chat part
of waking up rick
see you buddy
i was thinking of doing it all
throughout last night watching steve
kornacki but i didn't get there
right hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here